ah
[Music]
whale strikes did happen and there were
angry whales that would pursue boats of
Whalers when they're out hunting them to
take them down hi I'm Jim Delgado I'm a
maritime archaeologist and historian
I've been in the business for 45 years
and worked on over a hundred shipwreck
investigations today we're going to be
looking at shipwrecks in movies and TV
and judged how real they are
[Music]
lost
not gone
didn't have it's pure Hollywood we're
talking about Magellan's ships Fernando
my gallus or Ferdinand Magellan as he
was called went out into the Pacific in
the early 16th century he starts out
with five ships and basically one gets
home
the wrecks that were left behind one
went up on a beach and was burned the
other one sank so discovering a ship
from Magellan in an underground cave in
the Philippines ain't gonna happen
[Music]
come on
close those clothes would have been
first off not even still in a barrel
they would not have retained any
smelling but there's more to it that
also just makes me go
oh yeah right they're sitting in a cave
it's open Rain's Gonna get in there and
dry rot is going to set in real fast the
fact that you still have sales intact
after 400 years know that you have the
wood intact that you can walk around no
there's your gold you've been looking
for
you happy now oh
I've only worked on one wreck and we
found a tiny little bag of 58 silver
coins this myth of shipwrecks having
treasure has been disastrous for
archeology we know more about ancient
Roman Rex for example than we do about
the ships from this time period because
everybody thinks they're full of
treasure and treasure Hunters have just
torn them apart in the past that drives
me crazy
thank you
holy the gold yeah it would have
survived it would have been that way but
you start kicking gold over like that
that beautiful mask would have been
dented gold is soft so unless he wanted
to melt it down he was really not being
a smart treasure hunter
Chopper would not have been able to pick
this big heavy thing up it's not only
got the entire wooden Hull it's got
ballast it's full of rock at the bottom
the condition this thing is in no matter
the net or not it would have broken open
whenever we raise a ship we do so piece
by piece for about every dollar we spend
in Excavating a ship we spend over ten
dollars to take care of it and to
preserve it so it's rare when we'll
actually raise an entire ship I'd give
this a one out of 10 just for the eye
candy
foreign
no way I'd never try to thread a needle
like this it's way too tight and all the
wreck ships would be a clear warning
sign to me to not go there unless I had
a really good reason what we generally
call a setting like this is a ship trap
dangerous places where you've got a
narrow passage there are places with
reefs that generally aren't seen until
the last minute and that includes spots
like Bermuda and its reefs where there's
plenty of wrecks or the Dry Tortugas
famous in Pirate lore off the coast of
Florida
foreign
terrible as that is you see sharks
occasionally around Rex because wrecks
usually attract fish for sharks that's
ringing The Dinner Bell I'll give it a 3
out of 10.
okay
the submersibles are real they're the
mere one and the mirror two they're no
longer working but I've dived in those
subs I was
part of an expedition in 2000 and I came
back as Chief scientist we completely
mapped all of Titanic on the outside
these Subs are six feet in diameter
nickel steel really thick those tiny
little portholes are set in made a thick
loose sight because you have to
withstand six thousand pounds per square
inch pressure this gives you a sense of
just what the pressure is this is an
ordinary Styrofoam cup that I brought
down in a mesh bag tied to the outside
of the sub this full-scale Styrofoam cup
was made this small and this tough by
six thousand pounds per square inch
pressure
it's real footage so in making the movie
Cameron's actually explored a great deal
of Titanic and those things that dangle
down we see them on deep water metal
wrecks they're called rusticles but it's
not really a process of corrosion
there's a bacteria that lives down there
called titanica halamoni that was
discovered on the wreck and it actually
eats the metal Titanic is slowly being
eaten but it's not going to go away
anytime soon the scientists that we've
worked with estimate that there will
still be a recognizable Hull of Titanic
for hundreds of years
okay let's drive down to b-deck
this is absolutely 100 accurate these
robots are rovs for remotely operated
vehicles in my last mission to Titanic
in 2010 we didn't go in Subs we sent
those down and with these robots and
with Lighting systems you could see so
much more of Titanic
that's ugly's bed
this brings back a lot of memories
everything we saw for the most part is
real you see personal items I've never
seen the piano but it makes perfect
sense having seen other footage that
didn't make it into the movie from Jim's
Dives where you see remains of chests
that still have China wear in them when
they went into that cabin the first
thing you saw was that fireplace that's
real the bed is real now then they
reproduced that in the film to give you
that sense of being inside so I can see
the difference in what was shot on the
wreck with what was shot on set those
are the crisper clearer more color in
them whereas on Titanic the stuff's a
little Bluer and thanks to that work
that that Jim and the team did we have a
much better sense of the interior of
Titanic that we never would have had
before I'd give this film a 10 out of
10.
yes there's always a bit of license in a
movie
but I think this is a pretty good
impression of what happened when the USS
Indianapolis was torpedoed by the
Japanese submarine i-58 towards the end
of World War II of close to 1200 guys
316 were ultimately rescued this is the
single greatest loss of life in a single
ship that the U.S Navy suffered it
looked like three Torpedoes are launched
from the i-58 we have a sense from
Survivor accounts and looking at the
wreckage that at least two hit and one
did hit near the bow and basically blew
it off the other one hit a midships
which we also see happening
hitting at a midships right in the heart
not only opened up another big hole it
also killed the power and you see that
the engine room is not responding they
have lost steam they've got fuel oil on
fire electrical systems are down that
was the Fatal blow
[Music]
as to whether or not the Torpedoes going
all the way through where that's other
things it's hard to say now I've looked
as a merchant ship torpedoed by a
Japanese ship using the same type of
torpedoes what I saw was it creates a
bubble of super pressurized water that
just tears through the steel like it's
wet cardboard
you couldn't stay on the ship it was
going to be sure death if you can't get
that fire out the smartest thing to do
is to abandon ship generally abandon
ship is supposed to be a more orderly
thing but in something like this you
have Flames everywhere and men were
walking through those fires they were
being burned and it's full of fuel oil
that is rapidly spreading the fire not
only throughout the ship but on the
water clearly in that case there's no
time to get everybody in the boats and
do this in an orderly fashion so pretty
accurate particularly in Wartime
[Music]
the way they depict the sinking more or
less confirms not only what the Survivor
said but also Captain Hashimoto of the
i-58 who with his crew witnessed the end
of Indianapolis but what also helps
inform it was the rediscovery of the
wreck deep in the Pacific and that is
how a big ship like that even a heavily
armored warship no power no pumps fires
everywhere the ship opened to the sea is
going to go down that fast I would give
this
a 9 out of ten
[Music]
I can't watch this without thinking
their butt for the grace of God go I
this story speaks to a ship that only
became famous because an amazing book
was written about it and then a film but
in 1991 Andrea Gale a fishing vessel
sails out in this perfect storm that
claimed them and other ships many years
ago I was part of a team that went out
to try to find Andrea Gale and we didn't
find it but what the film shows is them
encountering basically a rogue wave
rogue waves usually are not storm waves
they're a big wall of water that's
formed elsewhere and come out of nowhere
on a otherwise calm sea they used to be
misbelieved it was a sailor story but
now that we have satellite views we can
actually see them from space forming and
moving this wall of water is pretty big
bigger than perhaps I might have thought
I think there's a little bit more of
Hollywood in that
there was nothing they could do other
than try to go over that wave if you
turned around and tried to run it would
have came right down on them and sent
them straight to the bottom
in some conditions ships do capsize when
a ship capsizes it's basically caught by
the Sea and rolled over if there's air
trapped inside the hull it can stay
afloat for some time in this case what
we see is that the air gradually comes
out as the ship is moving and the crew
deep inside are trapped this movie
captures the essence of what it means to
have to go to work on the sea and not be
able to come home for that I give The
Perfect Storm a 10 out of 10. hey look
balloons it is a party
[Music]
so what we see is a wartime wreck it's a
submarine as to whose it is hard to say
looks sort of like an American type sub
from World War II
um in a Minefield the type of mine with
those horns yeah that's a little more
common to say the World War One era than
the World War II era but yes there have
been submarines that have been found in
Naval minefields but you just wouldn't
have everything still floating around
because after Wars they spent a lot of
time and money going around and getting
those Minds out of there
perfect
foreign
that torpedo would have been deadly
explosives can last a long time
underwater anytime we've been on the
bottom on a wreck you stay away because
they could go off depending on how deep
the water is and the length of the
bubble created by the explosion it might
not be seen on the surface and maybe
only as a slight little bubble bath as
the two Pelicans experience my
granddaughter loves it and so in terms
of Kaylee's satisfaction Grandpa would
give it a 10 out of 10 for that in terms
of accurately depicting a shipwreck I'll
give it a five
foreign
what we see here is what we call
Progressive flooding ships are designed
to keep water out so when water starts
to come in if you can't get it out if
you can't keep pumping it out pumps are
the only means that you have to keep
water outside of the ship then you lose
your buoyancy and the ship will go down
this gives us a sense of when you're
caught in a storm and your ship takes a
battering and you just can't stop the
water from coming in
I've been in a storm at sea in weather
like this if they hadn't been able to
get the power back and to get the ship
upright I'd be down at the bottom of the
sea now with the rest of the team so
this brings back a pretty powerful
memory of how easy it is to go from ship
to shipwreck I'd give this film an 8 out
of 10 in terms of depicting a high seas
shipwreck caught in the grip of the sea
and bad weather
[Music]
foreign
strikes did happen and there were angry
whales that would pursue boats of
Whalers when they're out hunting them to
take them down what we're looking at is
Hollywood's depiction of nat philbrick's
book in the heart of the sea which tells
the story of the whaler Essex which on
the Pacific in 1819 was stove as they
said or rammed by a whale and sunk but
the whale damages more in this scene and
in a different way than what history
tells us Owen Chase is the mate his
story as well as the account of of the
captain talk of a whale that may just
have been confused and in that the edges
of the planks held together and keeping
the water out were pushed by the force
so the water began to come in but not so
fast as to immediately sink the vessels
the way they depicted things was a
little more rushed it stayed afloat for
enough time to elapse so these guys
could get supplies get their boats ready
and leave without a panic but
what they're doing is absolutely right
you take sales and other things so that
you can ring cover for you guys in the
Sun as well as sail and the fire that
didn't happen I'll rate the film based
on Nat's book about a seven
foreign
the steering a bit and they're turning
that starboard bow thruster to push
their vessel off of the other side so
turning bow thrusters alone which are
down in the hole and they basically have
propellers they're not really there for
navigation and I I doubt they would have
had enough effect and so plausible that
they knew what was going to happen and
we're just trying to keep it from
striking in and to give them a little
extra leverage to stay off the other
ship
foreign
given the angle they had it hit at it's
plausible those vessels are built strong
I could see that not punching through
and hanging up striking the other vessel
like that could have ended in them
locking up certainly slowing them down a
bit
wow it's possible they could have gone a
little further given the speed they were
but what kind of a sea wall is there if
it was running up on a beach then yeah
maybe I would say that the ship probably
would have stopped before that but then
you wouldn't have had that moment where
it comes in and scares the Taurus and
the guy with his fancy car and the
great scene with the dog barking defines
I mean that's just Hollywood at its most
dramatic best I'll give this a 7 out of
10 just because it's fun and it does
give you a sense of the power of ships
and why we try to keep them from hitting
each other
it's entirely possible for a ship to
break apart and to split particularly in
the early days when they're coming up
with welding as opposed to riveting
ships together so what we're looking at
is a depiction in film of a real life
event where two tankers and the one
we're looking at is Pendleton so split
into in a storm off New England in 1952
their World War II built tankers quickly
assembled welded and these T2 tankers as
they were called some of them had
welding problems and what happened with
these ships is they broke into bow and
Stern
it's entirely plausible these ships
particularly wartime built ships were
built knowing with the battle of the
Atlantic and U-boats torpedoing with
watertight bulkheads if you lost one
portion you could stay afloat in terms
of navigating it purposely being steered
into a Shoal that's not what history
says what history says is that it
drifted up there and it was driven there
by the force of the storm and the waves
so while this is a dramatic Hollywood
moment you do get the sense of these
guys keeping their head and keeping
steam up and some power so that they had
light I'll give it a 9 out of 10. at 800
feet passing through thermocline all my
life support is in the green
wow I've worn one of those suits in a
moon pool to test it out they're called
to one atmosphere suit basically it's
like a suit of armor that you wear like
a sub hard suits were rated to go
initially about 1500 feet down to two
thousand the depth they're at perfectly
right
it's a phantom jellyfish a phantom
jellyfish is absolutely real I think all
told less than 30 have been spotted on
deep sea missions they do glow and those
arms they can be about this big they can
be as deep we've seen as up to 21
000 feet and it's another reminder that
there's so much life down there that
seems alien to us but that we are
constantly encountering I've never seen
one this color those are uh we just lost
Jackson's vitals checking Vital Signs is
absolutely part of a mission you gotta
do it you got a human being in that not
counting Neymar and vibranium and all of
that in terms of depicting what these
suits do I'd give that scene a 10 out of
10. my favorite shipwreck in a movie or
a show has to be Titanic because it's a
wreck that everybody knows and it's a
wreck that has been depicted in movies
throughout time and all of them
ultimately focus on why I as an
archaeologist study shipwrecks these are
people stories and through shipwrecks we
learn more about
thank you for watching and if you
enjoyed this video why don't you click
on the video above